[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Kelly in Ohio I'm 23
and about a year out of ministry school
with no school debt since I work four
jobs and cash flowed everything so I'm
totally debt free way to go Kelly I work
at a professional Screen Printing and
embroidery shop and volunteer for
Ministry making $2 an hour I work 45
hours a week at the shop and after taxes
I'm at about 30 36,000 a year this is
the most I've ever made but when I
listen to the show I'm often confused at
what you all say is a good income to me
this is good income since I'm able to
save $1,100 a month towards a down
payment on a house what are your
thoughts do I need to be worried about
getting another job or is it about how
I'm budgeting all right a lot of
questions here first thing that comes to
mind is why do we go to Ministry
School uh you know if we go to Ministry
School and we've changed our mind fine
with that but if we went to Ministry
School to be in the ministry I'd want to
know what the path is uh to Ministry and
then once you get into Ministry depends
on what you're doing because people
don't go into Ministry to make money at
least the people that are actually about
Ministry so the question about good
income I think it's a a tadb bit
relative but if you look at the uh the
income scale in the United States 36,000
is is is obviously on the low side uh
but I love your discipline that you
actually have a budget and that on that
income uh because you have no debt and
you're living on less than you make uh
you know look you're saving some pretty
good money there so uh I don't think you
need to be worried about getting another
job no but the answer to that is what
job do I go to next because I doubt that
you want to be in this screen printing
and embroider embroidery business for
the rest of your life so if I was
sitting with you I'd say what's our
long-term plan or what are a couple
options that we are considering for the
long term and what I'm talking about
there are destinations and once we have
an idea on some destinations we can
start to choose direction direction is
always more important than destination
uh because the destination tends to
change but direction will get us going
and making progress so uh you're doing a
great job on budgeting and as you
increase your income with the way you
budget the more you save the more you
can invest yeah that's the proper answer
to your question also hidden in your
question was you didn't like it that we
said 36,000 wasn't a good income good
income is not a moral statement right
good income is relative to the average
household income in America which is
78,000 right
now and so if you make 36 as a single
person just out of school you are
considerably less than the average which
would also make up the average and
that's okay it's not the end of the
world it's not a you're not a bad person
you're not a horrible income earner
you're not lazy none of those are
judgments that are say when we say good
income all we're saying is relative to
the average yours is
low but somebody's got to make up the
average so the question is do you want
it to be you and so you know you start
thinking about where you want to be in
10 years if you're just out of school
let's call you 23 what do you want the
33 year old version of you to look
like detail it out Ken just told you
determine the the direction the
destination and then let's move towards
that rather than landing and being
satisfied and say well I've got margins
so I call this a income even if you all
don't well our our portion is not that
you can't live on it I think you're
doing a great job you're amazing you're
doing a great job with your budgeting
but your income is below average that's
another way of saying it ex rather than
saying a good income but so when someone
calls us and says they make you know
$160,000 that's
double the national average and so that
by definition is a good income it's
above average way above average
and so these days when you make six
figures you're above average the old
days when you made six figures you were
called Rich but nowadays you just can
buy Alpo but you know it's there you go
but that that's the thing I mean
so you know because Alpo have you seen
the prices no I'm kidding but so the
thing is Kelly that that you are doing a
good job and you're not spiritually are
psychologically wrong to be satisfied
right now with where you are however as
a person that tells you you know we want
to be anything that's not growing is
dying so let's be let's be something
that's growing let's be aiming at
something and have a destination create
your free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life